un largo abrazo después de meses de
ausencia el periodista estadounidense
danny fenster volvió a casa luego de
seis meses de incertidumbre detenido en
mianmar
todo el día no supe que estaba
regresando a casa estaba en la prisión
de yangon esta mañana y me dijeron que
empacar a una maleta con lo que
necesitara
me metieron a un automóvil esposado de
manos y pies me dijeron que no hiciera
preguntas o dijera nada
junto a él estuvo el ex gobernador de
nuevo méxico bill richardson quien ayuda
en las negociaciones con el país
asiático asegurando la liberación del
periodista con ayuda humanitaria y
vacunas contra él con 19
la liberación de danny sucedió en dos
semanas orgullos
hubo cuatro reuniones de las directivas
del centro richardson para el compromiso
global con el comandante en jefe de la
junta de mianmar yo le dije que esto
sería un regalo un gesto humanitario al
pueblo estadounidense y fue lo correcto
danny era un periodista haciendo su
trabajo
de
fenster de 37 años trabajaba como editor
de una revista en mianmar cuando fue
detenido por las autoridades y
sentenciado a 11 años de prisión por
cargos de incitación violaciones de las
leyes de inmigración y reunión ilegal
desde nueva york dijo que seguirá
luchando por los que permanecen
detenidos entre ellos por lo menos 47
periodistas más tienen a mi familia y
amigos en mianmar todavía no he podido
comunicarme con ellos todavía hay mucho
trabajo por hacer allí según la
asociación de asistencia para
prisioneros políticos más de 10.000
personas han sido arrestadas desde el
golpe militar del primero de febrero en
miami marc además cerca de mil 260
personas han muerto a causa de la
violencia durante las manifestaciones
por parte de las fuerzas de seguridad